i
ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
como se imagina en una ciudad inclusiva
a las ciudades los hacemos las personas
somos inclusivos como serlo no estoy
aquí para hablarles de algo técnico no
soy arquitecto y urbanista para hablar
de construcciones mi abogada para
hacerlo de legislación soy comunicadora
y una persona con discapacidad
pero la silla de ruedas no es la única
forma de discapacidad aunque es la forma
más fácil que encontramos para graficar
la para indicar que hay una condición
distinta porque si es visible y fácil de
entender para todos
soy gabriela man cayó del pozo y tengo
esclerosis múltiple
una enfermedad degenerativa del sistema
nervioso central en la que mis defensas
me atacan y crean cortocircuitos en el
cerebro y la médula espinal causando
varios tipos de discapacidades que a
veces se ven y otras no y es de lo que
quiero hablarles hoy de lo que sentimos
él
3 por ciento de personas con
discapacidad en el ecuador
déjenme contarles un poco cómo funciona
la esclerosis múltiple es cómo hacer un
mal bingo todos los días hay días en los
que no puedes caminar otros de los que
no puedes mover los brazos otros en los
que te olvidas las cosas pero estoy
pidiendo que ese no sea hoy hay otros
días en los que no puedes hablar o vela
pero dejemos de hablar de enfermedades
no vaya a ser que haya alguien
hipocondría con la sala hablemos de lo
que de verdad importa de cómo ser
inclusivos
y desde mi condición la mejor forma que
conozco de ser inclusivo de ser
empáticos
todos en alguna ocasión hemos dicho a
pobrecita no sé si tuviera la fuerza
para para vivir como lo hace ella
pero empatía no significa pena y empatía
significa conocer otras condiciones
desde el respeto y la igualdad
y entonces cómo podemos ser inclusivos
si nuestra en nuestras manos construir
accesos o hacer leyes
yo les traigo una idea
se puede generar inclusión desde el
lenguaje
revisemos primero los términos de los
que se identifican a las discapacidades
especial que se diferencia de lo común
general
tullido que ha perdido movimiento en sus
miembros mental que no tiene
el desarrollo mental corriente
manco que ha perdido un brazo o una mano
para telecom que tiene un defecto físico
en los pies
esta tal vez es la que a mí más me
impacta porque minusvalía significa
disminución de valor
entonces minusválido significa que vale
menos
y alguien aquí me puede decir a cómo
está cotizado un ser humano en la bolsa
la terminología para hablar sobre
discapacidad ha evolucionado con el
tiempo en el siglo 19 toda persona con
discapacidad cognitiva era llamado
idiota
en el siglo 20 el término evoluciona a
discapacitado
pero cuando le decimos a alguien
discapacitado le estamos dando una
sentencia en forma de adjetivo
porque estamos anteponiendo una
condición a un montón de características
más que tiene esta persona
en 1990 la onu acepta el término persona
con discapacidad para referirnos a
alguien que tiene una discapacidad
porque es más humano y respetuoso
desde una cuestión de corrección
política sino que estamos diciendo que
una persona tiene una condición de vida
distinta
en comunicación los términos en los que
nos referimos a los demás son el primer
paso para relacionarnos entre pares y
nos demuestra si lo hacemos con interés
con pena con respeto o con lástima
además nos muestran si conocemos de un
tema o no
lo que no se comunica no existe entonces
llamar a las discapacidades por su
nombre es lo más inclusivo que podemos
hacer
la
la inclusión desde el lenguaje en
realidad es como nos referimos en qué
términos nos identificamos a las
discapacidades
entonces cuando alguien me dice persona
con capacidades especiales me hace
sentir una superheroína
pero yo no tengo ninguna capacidad extra
cieguitos no personas con discapacidad
visual tal vez ellos sí tengan una
capacidad extra cuando yo tenía 7 años
estaba aprenda aprendiendo a montar en
bici
pero
tenía conocí a dos chicos que nunca en
su vida habían visto y ellos manejaban
con completa naturalidad mientras yo
todavía utilizado en las ruedas
auxiliares
gabriel giorgi en su libro formas
comunes nos habla del biopoder que tiene
el lenguaje porque cuando nombramos a
algo oa alguien lo ubicamos dentro del
imaginario colectivo de la sociedad en
un orden de importancia y lo inscribimos
políticamente
y la verdad es que yo creo en la
comunicación como la búsqueda del
sentido colectivo porque en este camino
de vivir con una enfermedad
discapacitante he pasado por un montón
de experiencias de enriquecedoras
les presento a mi familia
[Música]
somos tres y cuando mi hermano se graduó
era sumamente importante que yo esté en
el evento
pero estaba pasando por una crisis y
utilizaba una silla de ruedas
salir del tercer piso desde mi casa sin
ascensor fue complicado pero cuando
llegué a la universidad del auditorio
estaba lindísimo un montón de familias
emocionadas por los logros de los
graduados dos bloques de sillas un
pasillo angosto en la mitad para que los
chicos puedan ir a ver sus títulos pero
no había un lugar pensado para mí
[Música]
entonces me acerqué a la persona del
protocolo y le pedí que por favor retire
22 sillas para poder ubicarme
el encantado lo hizo y me ayudó a
parquear me y cuando terminó me dijo
listo ahí ya no estorba
que nuestro árbol
no me molestó lo impertinente de la
frase sino porque es así como vemos a la
discapacidad
el lenguaje expresa meramente lo que
pensamos las personas y en este sentido
no sólo lo que pensaba él sino toda la
sociedad
está claro que él no esperaba una
persona en silla de ruedas para el
evento la universidad no esperaba una
persona en esa condición
y entonces es aquí que quiero
recordarles la empatía
porque no vemos muchas personas con
discapacidad en las calles
mi vereda está en buen estado para que
una persona con discapacidad pase por
ahí
cuando me pareció en frente de una rampa
le interrumpe la circulación a alguien
[Música]
cuando utilizo los espacios
preferenciales le estoy quitando la el
derecho a alguien que si lo necesita
como me ayudó a cruzar la calle una
persona con discapacidad visual
la pena nunca ayuda a nadie dice mi
amigo juan pepe y yo le creo porque él
es de las primeras personas que me ayudó
cuando yo estaba en una crisis y lo hizo
sin incomodarse sino porque eso es lo
que hacemos las personas unas por otras
y la pena tiene este sentimiento de
superioridad en el medio que no nos deja
aceptar esas otras condiciones como
formas de vida distinta que tal vez
necesitan de decisiones o actividades
que nosotros no hemos requerido o
considerado siquiera
imagínense la diferencia si en el grado
de mi hermano la persona de protocolo
hubiese movido más sillas y me hubiera
dicho listo sólo es cuestión de
organizarnos
recapitulemos la inclusión desde
nosotros podemos generar la desde tres
de tres formas
desde la empatía sin pensar con respecto
refiriéndonos a los halos a las
discapacidades por su nombre llamándolas
por su nombre y esa es la forma más más
inclusiva que podemos tener
hablemos de tal vez para nosotros la
discapacidad sea un tema tabú
pero para quien lo vive es una realidad
entonces si ustedes quieren saber
pregunten nos las preguntas no ofenden
[Música]
porque no tienes un brazo porque no
puedes mover las piernas las preguntas
no o frente
demostrar interés permite que hay una
comunicación fluida entre las personas y
entonces cuando esto sucede dejamos de
ser ese objeto lejano de cristal al que
no hay cómo tocar o hablar
ya que así se me acaba el tiempo y como
comunicadora no me gusta quedarme nunca
pero no quiero irme sin preguntarles que
estamos haciendo con nuestras palabras
construimos algo
discriminamos a alguien incluimos a las
minorías el lenguaje tiene el potencial
de cambiar los comportamientos
porque como está la mano evoluciona con
nosotros y es la forma más cotidiana de
la cultura
usemos esta herramienta con sabiduría
para ser personas inclusivas y crear
ciudades inclusivas gracias
[Aplausos]